et donc ton but c'était d'aller voir des
gens en difficulté ouah c'est comme ça
qu'on dit voilà et leur management ah
ouais petit mot vous avez une belle
photo
et d'aller frapper des gens d'accord
pour dire la vérité ça m'est arrivé ça
jamais été diffusé mais effectivement il
ya eu ou non il ya eu fusion c'est
normal mais non contre moi et je me
défonce à celle des ados ouais ouais
alors on va commencer par quelques
séquences cultes parce que j'imagine
c'est vraiment très très drôle et où
pascal on revient sur les propos de ton
émission cette séquence a su devenir
c'est de la faute des énervés face
justement à certains d'entre eux il ya
tellement de journal à 5 6 dans
les
poteaux
submergé par la colère armand se jette
sur son marteau
moi
ça fait bizarre de voir ta aujourd'hui
ça fonctionne encore ouais mais est
celui avec qui tu avec ça a été coupée
c'est quoi c'est parce que c'était
vraiment c'est à accepter parce que ben
arfa dès les débuts de 18 d'un temps qui
était très costaud voix ouais j'en ai eu
quelques-uns qui était même entraîner
s'étaient entraînés ils voulaient volant
d en découdre avec moins d'options bien
sûr est apte à gagner à chaque fois j'ai
beaucoup de gens arrête toi tu as perdu
une fois jamais savez je me lèverai
troisième jeu 4 and take what he on est
à 80 de quoi le concours
des titres de champion de france devenu
champion d'europe de champion du monde
la tension est que j'adore parce
qu'évidemment on se souvient ça c'était
une séquence culte un armand et son
marteau sos ma famille a besoin d aide
voilà ccnr jose après donc ces vidéos
armand et sont
marqués ce qu'il vient de voir
bah c'est normal sarkozy fait encore un
homme à maille est
très drôle à manger en marcoux est
chouette ce qui est très bon et des bras
qui partent émission ya jack welch qui
est très très drôle mais grâce quel
retour le lit du jeune moundir aussi ça
c'est génial c'est mounir mounir aussi
la meilleure
je suis là c'est le meilleur damien
[Musique]
busto sacs jetables ou pas
comment est-ce que c'est d'en saisir
votre corps
devoir
en tout leur talent en plus bas
parce que tu peux m'appeler je parte
levé
par gentiment
non c'est vraiment c'est vrai c'est fini
je sais
que tu as acheté un morceau n'ont pas
tout de suite
on avait on a d'autres extraits mais ce
qui me fascine à cette émission c'est
que je me rendais pas compte à quel
point avec des gamins et souvent c'était
des mères célibataires ou dégoût des
parlers peuvent parler à leur mère cc
c'est hallucinant pas seulement en plus
non seulement ils parlent mal mais en
plus certains ont eu des gestes très
déplacé en ma présence est vraiment qui
se fait balayer au sol là nous
suppliaient de montrer les images ce
qu'on n'a pas le droit c'est interdit on
le sait et c'est de la violence par
intérim du club le gamin part
directement foyer donc on n'a jamais pu
montrer ce jour du match et pourtant les
parents signé pour ça qu'en même temps
tu restais dans la famille à l'époque
c'était toujours à tf1 douze jours on a
réduit à 6 jours à nrj12 et d'un jeu si
je fais à deux jours sur vivolta non
c'est
pas dur et deux épisodes 12 jours
c'était quand même beaucoup c'était jody
et pascal as cupide renseigner pour
savoir si ton passage avait vraiment une
les faits ce qui est des quizz positive
c'est en prison sur 152 familles on a eu
dix 10 échecs il existe fonction des
chalets un vrai mieux après sont tous
parents ils ont des enfants ils veulent
que j'ai le parrain barcella servat
c'est un
bon jeu peut pas que le parrain de tout
le monde soit plus facile maintenant tu
vas mettre que du coup tu as pensé à
faire un peu à leur pardon pour le
parallèle mais
une fondation jeunes
une fondation pour toutes et tous ces
jeunes en difficulté c'est ce que c'est
ce que tu fais là
surtout si tu lis un bouquin maintenant
donc pour les parents donc n'hésitez pas
à lâcher parents d'ados 25 conseils c25
conseil que j'avais déjà noté sur mon
premier livre a bola de très belles
photos merci et effectivement dans ce
bouquin va les parents m'appellent
aujourd'hui moi je suis un peu un peu
pris dans pas mal de projets et s'avère
que ba aujourd'hui si jamais je peux pas
aller les aider ils peuvent lire ce
bouquin étaient des gamins toi bien sûr
que vous bien oui les deux
business faut qu'ils se tiennent à
carreau kouadio bi c'est rien c'est fini
le bouquin est finie alors mathieu j'ai
mon fils qui bosse avec moi dans ma
salle de sport qui est fabriqué carré et
j'ai mon deuxième qui est également
éducateur d'accord mais non ils sont
menottés dans le regard
ils reviennent a aucun qui peut déraper
alors qu'on avait les jambes fraîches
oui je me suis tellement qui mettez vous
à chaque fois c'était fort ah ouais
moi je sais pas ce que moi je te
découvrir son jeu ces mêmes flicage leur
dit que ça veut dire moi j'ai déjà
voyagé ça veut dire bonjour tu viens
quartier toi non ouais ça veut dire quoi
guti c'est au regard des bons jours fait
franchement arrêtez de répéter des mots
sans savoir la signification et bonjour
c'est salam aleikoum situe pour la
langue or le parler tétouan écoute on va
apprendre à l'école
si tu dis wesh
moi je suis fan et je suis tellement fan
que je ne comprends pas mais vraiment
pas que la star ac alors j'adore jean
pascal est pourquoi la star ac n'a pas
pris toit pour gérer tous les gamins
landes en lice à tomas verner je pense
que je sais pourquoi cette f1 ouais mais
ça oui je suis parti un peu pas fâchés
mais j'ai quitté tf1 à l'époque on est
en plein de signatures de contrats s'est
pas entendus sur les contrats alors je
pense que je vais mal fait je suis parti
comme ça j'aurais peut-être pas dû donc
d'ailleurs je m'en excuse auprès de la
chaîne parce que c'est quand même grâce
à eux aujourd'hui j'en suis là mais il
faut quand même pas l'oublier donc mille
excuses aux gens de tf1 que j'ai pu
blesser mais c'est bien le dire en tout
cas voilà je faut savoir j'ai fait une
faute voilà j'assume c'est comme ça et
effectivement où j'ai appris ici jean
pascal mais il a fait la star ac' aussi
il a participé en tant que tel candidat
mais bien sûr
qu'il a hérité d'un problème sont pas
des cassos non plus les planètes se
tenait prêt à tenir il faut le tenir et
puis c'est pas des casseurs
on avait encore sur ma fiche de marquer
quand à [ __ ] c'est un garçon
je crois pas qu'il ait
atteint ne coupera pas que pascal vient
d'entrer dans la maison
non non non
non jamais dit ça parce que j'ai entendu
je crois non non je vois tu m'insultes
certains c'est sûr de toi oui non ses
pattes il occupa du coin à wayne tu sais
que c'est toi c'est moi qui te vois tu
me vois arriver tu me vois là j'entends
une insulte les six roads était squatté
pardon c'est pour dire que y'a bon jour
déjà chaud bonjour qui contient ou
bonjour qui bonjour tu veux que ton âme
yab londres l éducation de pedro voir
ses émissions l'a
dit c'est quoi ces cas mieux rideau de
ton émission sportive
ouais c'est cet extrait on peut les voir
mon coeur et cartonne mathieu et moi je
vais poser une question à pascal comme
on le voit là tu avais vraiment quelque
chose d'hyper théâtrale est ce que tu as
pris est ce que tu as été un peu coacher
est-ce qu'à l'époque tu t'es un peu
entraîné jamais su répéter
je suis je suis comme ça c'est moi
mouais ma personnalité mondiale et
cameyrac tu sais gérer que tu sèmes
attaques ont essayé ces [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
à
placé
jeudi en juniors seniors qui diront
jamais où on l'attend
[Applaudissements]
et la colère ça commençait à mettre 80
bataillon
mais pas la taille qui fait l'homme oui
[Applaudissements]
mais de savoir si on battait tous les
deux balles quand la 4è du cadre elle a
une petite
je pense qu'il nous attend chez eux
je pense en blanc je fais des
petits bras ce bras de fer
c'est horrible ce que je vais vous dire
j'ai de la sixième à la terminale j'ai
battu qu'une seule personne mais fort et
c'était une classe à vendre cinquième
essai
à bella je lui fait peur je peux te dire
lazcano vos clics c'est des méthodes
éducatives
alors il sert de 25 c'est un conseil que
j'ai développé parce que j'ai fait un
premier bouquin où ça a parlé un petit
peu de moi et de tf1 les poster un petit
peu oui tu peux tu dors je te l'offre je
sais que t'as pas d'ado mais bon non
j'ai pas d'enfants dans la famille sinon
vous vous signaler ces méthodes là vous
les avez l'a appris avant de faire les
émissions ça va partir parce que moi
j'ai vécu sur le terrain ce que je
l'écris de dix ans après mon premier
bouquin je n'étais pas prêt pour un pont
pour en faire un deuxième jeu il est
peut-être temps de maintenant de
reprendre les 25 ans et du début c'était
en 2000 2010 et j'ai développé donc j'ai
travaillé longuement et je me dis allez
voir on va enfin les écrire et c'est pas
vraiment des conseils afin de sonder clé
en l'été parce que je suis pas le
premier conseil à qui que ce soit on
donne des clés jouveau des portes je
vais vous secouer dans votre
problématique et peut-être qu'il ya la
solution ce bouquin qui est marrant
c'est que parent c'est un métier qu'on
n'apprend pas à quoi ça servirait qu'à
plein de gens nous font des enfants
terribles enfants turbulents ou t'en
veux dire mais arrête de faire ça arrête
de dire ouais tout mais des nord est en
fait les gens ils s'adorent ils sont
très vite débordés oui les clients
étaient débordés et tu sais comme
l'ajout ramsi m'a dit est ce que vos
parents vous disais souvent je t'aime
non faut se croit pas on faisait pas
beaucoup mais il m'aimait quoi mais vous
le saviez mais ce qui vous le disais il
faut le dire quand tu dis je t'aime à
quelqu'un directement sa secrètes de la
sérotonine donc toutes ces choses là où
il faut prendre les gens dans les bras
parce que sinon après il y aura un
mouvement de recul pas oui toutes ces
choses là ça s'apprend après voilà donc
ce grand voyage poursuite bouquillon
c'est plus de crise on a
dérapé comment revenir sur le droit de
jeu
pas toujours ceux des familles
dysfonctionnelles pas vrai tout moi j'ai
des familles
qui en moi qui m'ont appelé pour me dire
comment on peut contacter pascal parce
qu'on n'y arrive pas ça on se souvient
d'ailleurs ouais mais c'est parce
qu'elle y retourne son lit comme ça et
là ça va être à temps j'en ai un autre
quand même qui m'amuse et bien david
sujet verbe complément sulige jeu par
les épaules garçons font déjà preuve on
a déjà prouvé des preuves c'est vrai
exercice a déjà fait tes preuves on
apprend à t'exprimer
jusque-là voila voila quoi sert un verre
ça c'est moi ce débouché des traces
ouverte sujet confirme on étudie comment
ça prend vraiment avec la foi d'un mois
une réponse d'apprendre quoi bas et des
chais pas des mots tout qu'est-ce qui
doit sa caisse que je dois savoir sur la
drh doit déjà c'est pas français ça et
alors c'est une erreur de français
renoncent aux besoins grave c'est que
stéphane mbia bref c'est tout c'est pas
mal qu'est ce que tu manges après s'il
est sage à brest mais d'après julien qui
sont les dames aussi
parce qu'elle la voit jamais évidemment
c'est ce que je vais dire mais trois
essais des secrets de prod mais moi qui
étais producteurs de plein de trucs tu
entends peau s'il était mon rêve il ya
aussi une part d'organisations du
tournage qui fait que tu créé des
situations mais bon c'est vrai je suis
pas d'accord avec ça tu vas dire non
voilà c'était truqué non
non c'est parce que je dis non du tout
du tout gai des stimuli
non mais moi je vais expliquer on
travaille en amont pour pouvoir faire un
document que vous appelez le séquentiel
c'est mercier et ce séquencier en fait
les jamais respecté ça se passe jamais
comme nous on le souhaite sur le terrain
sourit donc quand on envisage de faire
une activité sportive d'activité où je
classe des assiettes parce qu'on était
assez critiqué là dessus sur le cassage
de d'assiette et on est en fait que ça
se fasse pas vraiment comme comme c'est
écrit donc en fait on a un séquencier on
a un document de travail et on essaie
dessus mais parfois ça ne fonctionne pas
dans cette émission l'avantagé que
j'étais libre de faire ce que je voulais
quand je voulais je pouvais parler à ma
façon et ça fonctionnait pas bon ont
changé on changeait de ce qui avait été
noté mais tellement parce que ce que
fait mme cissé beaucoup maintenant ils
l'ont fait avec damidot l'ofec plaza
c'est à dire des gens qui incarne
vraiment leur programme tf1 n'a fait un
moment donné avec toi oui avec comme ça
que ces manuels ces manuels
bâtisseur là bien là manuel
ce serait cocasse et ça ils ont ils ont
ils ont arrêté est ce que je trouve un
passé après tout est passé un petit peu
sur nrj 12 j ai eu quelques unes numéro
mais ça passe
à côté et
on l'a fait cinq ans que c'est vrai
c'est pas ça c'est qu'à l'époque j'étais
la star de la scène les équipes c'est
vraiment
je confirme je confirme qu'ils n'avaient
pas pour le coup plus jeune ça et puis
après ça c'est ça s'est arrêté ça c'est
non j'ai ensuite et c'est c'est à partir
de 6 8 12 et à cet arrêté c'est la merde
à la tma arrange pas du tout c'est si
vite qu'à planter ton émission je vais
pas dire qu'elle a planté je peux pas
dire ça mais on a décidé d'arrêter
effectivement la production elle s'est
méritée pour quoi vous couper donc non
c'est 8 a décidé d'arrêter son émission
c'est ça mais tu as un autre projet que
témoin l'a proposé et que je trouve est
formidable c'est le cas non puisque tu
veux tu mens pas aux nouvelles à
annoncer un peu tard parce que c'était
sur le bas la chaîne youtube qui
fonctionne tout cela mais il avait une
idée géniale tu voulais faire passer le
bac à des jeunes en difficulté
oui exactement la discipline est déjà en
difficulté au moment du bac c'est là
qu'olivier al justement on avait écrit
ce projet et puis on s'est présenté
devant la direction de ses huit toits
rouges a été refusé
je serai à cyril j'irai c'est fait c'est
fait c'est fait c'est fait et je dis
ouais mais je suis de lormont
c'est comme ça la cave est super bien
sûr l'origine pour faire encore un petit
peu
les jumeaux qui savent pas
comment ça se passe justement une
religion mais ça dépend ça dépend ça que
quand tu sors pas tout l'afpa non c'est
quand j'y vais comme quand tu as promis
ne soit pas te laver
ça va quand même temps qu'à tenir une
chine qui ne prend pas
magnifique je crois que tu es le mec le
plus sale que j'ai rencontrés jusqu'à
maintenant et pourtant des gens sales et
j'en ai rencontré jeudi pas dans ton
caleçon la sauvette un enfer
moi c'est dans le camp des mois sur moi
même pas les dons ça c'est pas l'odeur
des pieds que je pensais aux gens de ta
bouche
c'est pas possible ça
question est-ce que c'était
systématiquement dans des familles est
extrêmement modeste mais c'est tout ou
parfois c'était des gens le père est
avocat pas mais je ne les ai jamais
revus ah oui on a eu des familles avec
d'un chef d'entreprise très riche
laurence en belgique en belgique en
belgique
et ce truc c'est que lui c'est un
personnage de folie quand on dit il
revint l'été parce qu'il a des punchline
parce qu'il sait exactement parler aux
gamins il fait un peu les chauffer il
sait être le grand phare à la fois les
provoquer enfin voilà il est très fort
et ce qui me tient c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les enfants qui ont dix ans me
connaissent ils étaient panel
des vidéos mais grâce à youtube a que
squeeze regarde aussi beaucoup aimé lui
et vidéos alors hier son gardien
auxiliaire
j'ai discuté avec un patron de chaîne
savait pas lequel tout mon fou que je ne
peux pas vous mentir
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas trop le sel qui demande à
voir et voilà mais c'est toi j'ai dit
j'adorerais du coup à part dont julien
mais tu viens chez moi et j'adorerais
bam reproduire pascal en demandant à 0,1
point tu sais pas on sinon
la chaîne mais je travaille sur tout cas
vraiment sur une autre chaîne et ce
serait formidable je promets est ce que
vraiment il faut que tu reviens tu as
une personnalité pas de cesser cet effet
pour la td et pourquoi on n'avait pas
faim business carrément de d'abord les
gens les masterclasses une sorte
d'agencé le tout de suite j'ai pas envie
sur la misère des gens et qu'ils
paieraient c'est pas mon truc des
maghrébins et de quoi tu dis aujourd'hui
vécu alors je vise la chaîne youtube un
petit peu la salle oui j'ai eu du
bouquin si bien sûr les gens achètent
ouais donc voilà il y avait une pièce de
terre que métier d'être annulée donc
pour l'instant on va rester sur place et
non pas sur les planches d'accord là
donc j'ai un côté times a aussi vu ce
que tu veux que ton fils bien sûr il est
à des sports ouais voilà on sauve samedi
dernier aller à nice
lallaoui cd pas toujours très propres
allons-y
ah ouais ok d'accord
quand tu peux vivre là dedans quand je
comprends pas ça pue ça pue la dent
comment on peut juste comme ça c'est pas
possible wendy ritchen sa 10e tu es fan
de ces mecs là ce mec là quand tu vas
voir ta piaule déjà dire toi tu es une
fan oublie moi je crois la même et
écrire une chanson le titre est mimi
cracra il va se faire un plaisir de
chanter sa taille son accent anglais
mais me quoi quoi mais me pourquoi à
tous
[Applaudissements]
et très pas bouger ses muscles tout le
temps tout le temps en permanence hâtif
de pion dans cinquante deux ans quand
même déjà mais au contraire ça c'est son
commerce
avec un garde du corps daudet qui avec
un peu d'eau les toits naturellement
c'est bien sûr que tu pascal parce qu'on
est évoque la possibilité du retour de
son ami c'est absolument vrai de travail
ce type de programme ça fait un peu
partie de la grande famille des
téléréalités et comme toutes les tailles
de sociétés docu
simplement est ce que toi aussi tu as
ressenti qu'à la fin les laisse jaillir
les candidats les jeunes que tu avais en
face de toi était peut-être plus rodés
et en connaissant eux mêmes le programme
qu'elle serait des attitudes qu'ils
adaptent est en fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire le naturel et la
spontanéité du début est ce qu'elle sait
pas un peu évanoui au film en métaux nam
en ont en fait il se demandait à canon
j'arrivais sa 6000e toujours leurs
questions ils arrivent quand pascal
hennuy
laquelle on mange arrive nous dit ouais
mais c'est bizarre talata les clés des
portes de tout le monde a fait condamner
tallec lui trouve la porte tu rentres
chez les gens parce qu'en fait je ne
sais pas parce que je dis ou pas ouais
allez bon allez n'exclut si ça vous
intéresse
en fait qu'entamer caméra quand la prod
arrive je suis déjà sur place j'ai un
casse et japon le clash et quand le
clash arrive je débarque
le ballon c'est une arrivée celle
établie mais ça s'appelle mis sur
produits systèmes et les ja la famille
va forcément le savoir le
la loi les caméras et où il ya les
canada
j'attends trois jours quatre jours et
puis c'est gênant question est ce que
maintenant sans caméra il ya des gens
qui tapent elle va pour jour donc tu es
payé comme réalisateur bar mitzvah tout
ça va tu vas sur des pays pour aller
à domicile bien sûr ah ouais c'est vrai
je croise des familles à domicile parce
que tu confonds voir combien ça je
prends comme mieux comme ça je connais
pas d'argent non mais j'y arriverai
pardon j'ai un frère
connard
vainqueur en difficulté voilà on
s'appelle et puis on discute si tu me
dis voilà il ya d'abord une semaine pour
le remettre dans le droit chemin à peu
près tu es à la journée tu es comment
s'agit d'un concept de stars ou en fonte
de sarko tu es là tu as donc on sait pas
ce que cette bascule il vit très mal le
fait que son frère soit une énorme
vedette
mais c'est le prince harry c'est une
seconde nature combien je veux dire je
me demande si c'est pas plutôt toi que
je dois côté oui
on n'aura pas les montants mais j'espère
vraiment qu'on va contre je promets ça
c'est vrai que j'ai parlé au patron de
chez nous hier il m'a dit c'est vrai que
ce mec c'est c'est incroyable et quand
on voit plus les gens dépensent plus
pour s'acquitter commence aujourd'hui
toujours ont fait danser une question de
talent oui et tu va très bien et est
très beau et tout va très bien et en
plus que des vignes qui tu adores